اكثر من عشره الاف طلقه جنود وعربات
عسكريه وخطه حربيه هجوميه لخوض حرب شرسه
ضد العدو لكن العدو هنا مجرد طائر طائر
الايمو
الجيش الاسترالي خاض في 30 القرن الماضي
اغرب معركه له في تاريخ العسكري
القصه بدات في فتره كانت الدوله
الاستراليه تعاني ويلات الكساد العظيم
الحرب العالميه الاولى كانت قد انتهت للتو
ومخزون المياه العذبه اوشك على النفاذ بعد
الحرب منحت استراليا بعض المحاربين
القدامى بعض الاراضي القاحله التي تحتاج
لاصلاح زراعي وبالفعل تمت المهمه بزرع
محاصيل القمح لكن وقع ما لم يكن في
الحسبان عدو تسلل واكل وخرب المحصول وشرب
مياه الري وهذا العدو كان طائر الايمو
الضخم
يزن طائر الايمو من 30 الى 50 كيلوجراما
ويصل ارتفاعه الى مترين وهو احد اكبر
الطيور على هذا الكوكب
سرعته فائقه وقد تصل الى 50 كم في الساعه
في هذه الحرب نفق ما يقرب من الف طائر منه
العدو هو لصمت غزير الاعداء مهاجر من
السهول الرمليه غزا في نوبه من الجوع بعضا
من افضل الحقول الزراعيه في وقت نضج
الحصاد ليقتات على المحاصيل بمنقاره
الشريف اسراب من الايمو بلغت اعدادها اكثر
من عشرين الفا اقتحمت المزارع وهددت
انتاجها ما دفع اصحاب تلك المزارع الى
التقدم بطلب لوزير الدفاع الاسترالي انذاك
ارادوا من خلاله موافقه حاسمه لمهاجمه
الطيور بالرشاشه والدبابات والغريب ان
وزير الدفاع وافق على الفور وامر بارسال
المدافع رفقه جنود من الجيش حرب غير
متكافئه على الاطلاق بين جيش مدجج
بالاسلحه وطائر لا حول له ولا قوه
طيور الايمو كانت سريعه وذكيه في رده
فعلها اخترعت للاحتماء من نيران الجنود
وسط الاشجار القريبه وبهذه الاستراتيجيه
لم يسقط سوى ما يقرب من الف طائر ايمو حتى
ان القائد العسكري للعمليه كان معجبا بقوه
خصمه
استمرت الحرب العسكريه على الايمو الى ان
تدخل البرلمان الاسترالي الذي شنه هجوما
على العمليه وبدات الصحف بالسخريه من
خساره الجنود لهذه المعركه لكن الحكومه
قررت في خطوه وصفت وقتها بالمتهوره تسليما
مزارعين انفسهم اسلحه وذخيره للتعامل مع
تلك الطيور وبالفعل قتل ما يقرب من 57 الف
طائر من الايمو خلال سته اشهر فقط من
العام 1934